okay hi there in this tutorial i'm going
to be covering php sessions now sessions
are quite similar to cookies however
sessions only have a temporary um
time
expiration if you like
they will be destroyed as soon as the
browser is closed uh or the connection
to the page is lost if that makes sense
so they're not like cookies you can't
set an expiration time in particular
and they're not stored in the same way
um i mean the id of the session can be
stored in a cookie
or you might have seen in a um
browser url uh something like um
uh like i can't remember the um the name
is like something equals and just a load
of uh sort of numbers and uh i think
letters are included as well but anyway
basically our um
our sessions are similar to cookies
however they're not they're not uh
stored for a long period of time only
until the user closes their browser
okay so sessions are a bit different
what we need to do is first of all we
need to declare um
or rather
call this function called session start
now this needs to be at the top of every
page that you use sessions in so if you
don't have this and you're trying to
either echo out a session value or
you're trying to set a session it won't
work you need this session start code in
there in a minute i'm going to show you
the error that comes up when you don't
use this so you'll know for the future
now to create a session it's very easy
we use dollar underscore session
and then in square brackets we give the
name of the session this is just going
to be name and we just equal this value
to something it can be string data it
can be numerical data whatever you like
okay so we've got our session set here
let's presume that i'm just going to run
this for the first time
refresh okay nothing's happened now if i
again um
like i did in my cookies tutorial if you
haven't already seen that check it out
but i'm going to comment out this code
and then what i'm going to do is echo
out the value of the uh session i've
just set
so that's name now bear in mind this is
not going to be run so this could be on
a completely different page for you know
but basically i'm just starting my
session i'm getting a um session called
name that's already been stored by our
server so let's refresh we can see that
that's equal to alex so
you could add this and this code on any
page so you can add your session start
and echo session name on any page as
long as this has been started on any
page in the current session of the
browser so for example if i was to
create a new page and add my php code in
and let's say session
start
and we're going to echo out
echo out um
the session
name the one i've just set i'm going to
save this out in my sessions folder as
uh newpay or new.php
so when we come back to our page here
and we click on
here and type new.php
we get exactly the same value even
though we're not working from the page
that we created our session we're still
able to access it
however if i was to close my browser and
reopen it this session probably wouldn't
would still not exist
okay then right let me just show you
what happens if you don't put your
session starting you get similar to
this oh and let's go back new php
yeah in fact i mean
what's happening what's happening here
is we're not actually getting any output
the reason being we haven't started our
session by putting our session start in
you can see
that we get our value out now the reason
it's not coming out for me at the moment
is because i don't have that type of um
error reporting on but if you did have a
specific type of error reporting turned
on i have a tutorial on that as well
then you'll see that you will probably
get an error
so you can close this off now and i'm
just going to show you how to unset a
session
now the way to do this is to basically
say either unset and then session in
brackets that will answer our session or
what we can do is we can use a
completely different command altogether
and that is
session
destroy
and the difference between these two
commands is session destroyer will
completely destroy um sessions that you
um currently hold um unset will unset a
particular session so it's up to you
really if you're saying logging you use
out and you'd say session destroy
and that would basically clear all
current
session variables that you hold um at
the present time um otherwise you can
just unset a specific one
so what is
sessions use what are sessions useful
for if you say entered a website and had
the chance to um
check a box saying remember me
if you didn't check this box then you'd
probably be using sessions because once
the user's browser has been closed the
user will be logged out
and when they come back onto the website
they won't they'll have to retype their
details say their username and their
password to come back into the website
if you're using cookies
this is different because you set an
expiration time
which means that the
user will be logged in or this cookie
will be held
until the user decides to destroy it and
we'd have to create code to destroy our
cookie like shown in my cookie tutorial
so really
it's up to you whether you use sessions
or cookies sessions are good for short
term cookies are good for a long term
specific amount of time that you want a
piece of data to be held but if you go
on to my um
php project
register and login you'll see that i use
sessions this is just because i'm used
to using sessions when i'm
creating tutorials however you can um
take um
any uh
form of this it could be a cookie it
could be a session it's really up to you
whether you want to keep the user logged
in
for a long period of time or not
so if you've got any questions on this
at all sorry for rambling on but just
feel free to contact me if you have any
questions
make sure you subscribe and i'll see you
around thanks for watching
okay welcome to a tutorial on php
cookies now cookies are really important
part of when you're creating especially
a website where you need to store
information about a user now the
definition of a cookie is a
a set of data if you like
stored on your computer so the user's
computer
by the web server
so for example when you log into a
website your details are stored for when
you next come back to that website if
you've say selected an option like
remember me
so you don't have to keep logging in
if you don't check
a button such as
remember me you'll probably be dealing
with sessions which close as soon as the
browser or the sorry as soon as the user
closes their browser
so sessions are killed straight away
however cookies are stored for later use
now
i'm going to get straight on and show
you how to create a cookie this is using
the set cookie function
and inside takes i think five parameters
but i'm just going to be using three
and the first vital one i'm going to use
is the name of the cookie which i'm
going to set to name
the second one is the data that needs to
be stored inside this
cookie and mine's gonna be alex because
my name is alex
now the next one's a bit more tricky
it's the time in which it expires now
this needs to be set in seconds
and
to represent this i'm going to create a
variable called exp for expire
and this is going to be equal to the
time and i'm going to add some value
onto here
so at the moment i'm adding nothing so
if i were to say echo this out and i'm
going to get rid of this cookie function
for now i'm just echoing out this time
uh thing here just to show you what it
does so let's refresh
you can see we've got quite a long
number here now this is the
unix timestamp and the unix timestamp is
basically the amount of seconds before
january the 1st 1970
so january the 1st at 12
a.m
um
in the year 1970
so we can see that adding the amount of
seconds onto here equates to
a date in the future
so for example at the moment you can see
that it's 88 now 89 and as i keep
refreshing
by every second this increases
so yeah this is quite a useful way of
adding a specific value onto here now we
need to find out the time in seconds um
of let's say
a day because i so i want this cookie to
expire in a day
um all i need to do is just say 24 times
60 so that get gets us um the amount of
minutes
uh in a day and then we can times it by
60 to get the amount of seconds in the
day which is 86 400. so if we change
this to 86 400 we now have a variable
expire
that um holds the type time in the
future by a day
so what we can do here is um
uncomment this and we can add our expire
variable in here so this is basically
going to set our cookie called name with
the value of alex and it's going to
expire in a day written in seconds using
this time function here
so let's refresh this page and we can
see
okay we've got no error so i presume
that's worked now what i'm going to do
is use my block commenting to just
comment out the rest of this
and underneath what i'm going to do is
i'm going to echo out this cookie now
the reason i've commented this out is
because you don't need to set a cookie
every time the user comes into the page
if you're using say a login script to
let the user log into a website you only
need to issue this once
and then the the cookie will be stored
and you can use it um
you know within this time that we've set
here
so what i'm going to say here is i'm
going to say echo i'm going to use
dollar store dollar sign sorry
underscore cookie and then inside here
is the name of the
cookie starts name so if i refresh here
you can see that that's alex and i'm not
going to do it even if you even if i
closed my my browser reside my computer
came back onto this page here it would
still read alex because it's been stored
on my computer
okay now um if i were to set another
cookie say uh let's just
we'll bring it down here let's say i'm
going to set another cookie
and this is going to be
age
and my age is 19
and my expiration time i'm going to keep
as this so let's just put this up back
up here
and we can
get rid of this i don't want to make it
too messy so we've got our expiration
time and i'm going to set another cookie
under here and that's going to be
the same expiration time if i can
get it right okay so what we're doing
here is i'm going to get rid of this
we're setting another cookie with the
same expiration time let's refresh
okay that's been set so now what i can
do is comment this out and underneath
here i can echo out that as well so you
can see we can set more than one cookie
in a page
let's just refresh that and i get 19. so
really what you can do here is construct
a sentence and what i could do is i
could say echo
cookie
name
and then concatenate is
and then concatenate
my age
so therefore we will have a sentence
saying alex is 19 just from the cookies
that we've stored and again if i close
my browser and restart my computer for
example or come back on say two hours
later this information will still be
there stored on my computer ready to use
by this page
so you can see that they're really
really useful to use
and also really easy to create as well i
knew and
easy to echo out to the user now there
is a function and we can use uh print r
and we can open underscore and we can
echo out dollar underscore
cookie here
making sure we put our line terminator
on and if we refresh here
we can see that we've got
a um
an array here and we have a different
value we've got name and that is equal
to alex and we've got an age which is
equal to 19. so basically this is
telling us the cookies that are have
been set and the values of them cookies
so this is also quite useful if you need
to echo this out to yourself
okay now there's another function which
i'll cover in the second part of this
tutorial and i'm going to use um
a ifs and if statement to find out if a
cookie's set or not and
yeah that's about it and then i'm going
to show you how to unset a cookie so
join me in part two and i will teach you
how to do that thanks for watching see
you soon
okay so just to summarize in the first
part of this cookie tutorial we learned
how to create cookies we learned how to
give an expiration date to the cookie
we learned how to print out specific
cookies and also using this command here
we learned how to print out every cookie
that we'd stored
so the next thing to do is assuming we
have created these cookies i'm going to
use this specific cookie here that i've
created to check whether it does exist
or not so to do this we're going to use
a
a function called is set and this
basically returns a true or false value
whether um
something is set or not so for example a
cookie and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say dollar sign underscore
cookie and i'm going to put name in
there
so this is basically reading out in
english language if
the cookie name is set then we need to
say echo
cookie is set
right otherwise we're going to echo out
to the user
cookie is not set
okay so by refreshing this presuming
that i have set my cookie and
everything's working i refresh and we
get the message cookie is set now this
ties into the fact that now i'm going to
teach you how to unset a cookie
so let's say up here just before if
statement i was to unset a cookie so
unset cookie now i'm going to unset just
this name one because
presuming you know how to unset this one
you can also unset this one so i'm gonna
i'm gonna unset this name cookie here so
to unset we basically use the same
command
and that's just setting it again so
we're resetting a cookie
just doesn't seem to make sense but it
will soon
and we're gonna set the cookie name to
nothing
and our expiration date
up here
i'm gonna create a new one called exp
unset
and that is going to be equal to
the time
minus eighty six thousand four hundred
here we said plus this would mean that
the time is in the future now by setting
a cookie to this variable which is a
time in the future we're actually
unsetting the cookie
so if i was to say
set a cookie called name or the cookie
that already exists called name to no
value no value
at all and using
exp
on set variable this will basically set
it to a time in the future therefore
unsetting our cookie
so if i get rid of this code for now
what i'm just going to do is i'm going
to run this page
okay nothing's happened presuming that
my cookie is on set
now i'm going to get rid of this code so
i'll comment this out
and i'm going to put my if statement
back into my page
now presuming this says is the cookie
set name and we've just unset the cookie
we should get the result cookie is not
set so let's refresh
and we've got cookie is not
and then from there on you could set it
again if you'd like
we can change the values of a cookie i
mean to change a value of cookie
you'd be using this command again
and basically you'd be saying set cookie
name and you'd just be typing a new
value inside here so it's not hard to
work with cookies
it's quite an easy process and it's a
really really useful thing in php so
use it to your heart's content
okay thanks for watching if you've got
any questions please let me know
make sure you subscribe to receive video
updates and i'll see you guys around
soon all right bye-bye
hi this is alex from php academy and
welcome to this php tutorial on the
ternary operator
in this video we're going to be writing
a short piece of code
and i'm going to demonstrate how we can
make this a lot shorter
by making use of the php's ternary
operator
so i'm going to create an example
application which is going to involve an
if statement or a couple of if
statements we'll see in a moment
and it's essentially going to check if a
user is old enough to do something
you know there's no context around this
but we're going to be using this as an
example just so we can
show two examples of the ternary
operator
so let's go ahead and write our sample
program where you know it's going to be
not a long
long piece of code but it will be
unnecessarily long um
anyway
so i'm going to go ahead and create a a
variable called age and i'm going to set
this to 18.
the next thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to create an if statement to set a
particular variable to true or false
depending on whether the user is old
enough so essentially i'm just going to
say if
and i'm going to say else
here
so we have
the condition here is going to be if the
age is greater than or equal to 18
i'm going to set this variable old
enough uh to true
otherwise i'm going to go ahead and set
it to false
now we could of course remove this else
altogether and just create the variable
old enough equals false here
so it's essentially guilty until uh
proven uh innocent
so you know we could leave it like this
it doesn't really matter
okay so now what i'm going to go ahead
and do is create another if statement
and this is going to check whether this
old enough variable is
uh equal to it was equal to true and if
it is equal to true i'm going to echo
something out otherwise i'm going to
echo something else out
so we do need an if else here
so i'm going to say if old enough
is equal to true i'm using the triple
equals that's just comparing type as
well
um
other tutorials that do explain that
and i'm just going to echo out old
enough okay very simple
and then if the user isn't old enough so
if this uh old enough variable has
remained with the value of false
i'm just going to say not old
not old
enough
okay so there's nothing
you know too complex about this
however for such a simple
piece of code or such a simple operation
we've used a lot of if statements
where they may not be necessary um so
let's go ahead and look at the result of
this
you'll see at the moment we've got old
enough if we change this to say
i don't know 16
we get the result not old enough so you
know that's how it works uh that's what
we're doing here
now what we can do is we can make use of
the ternary operator to actually shorten
this to one line
and this to one line now for such a
short application it doesn't really
um you know it doesn't really matter but
you know if you have uh a long along um
a long file in file length i guess in
line size you're going to want to make
use of the tenery operator to try and
shorten everything
a bit more
so let's go ahead and first take a look
at the syntax of the ternary operation
i'll explain how it works
and then we'll take a look at shortening
these
so if i come down here i'll explain the
syntax
essentially what i'm going to do is i'm
going to i'm going to be doing something
before the ternary operator so i'm
either going to be
echoing or setting a variable equal to a
specific value
and then after this we have a pair of
brackets which represent a condition as
you would normally find in an if
statement
now what we have is very slightly more
confusing uh it's a question mark and
this is basically like
anything after this is the first block
of what we want to do
if this condition is met
and then we have a colon where so
here is if this condition is met
and here is if this condition is not met
and then we just pop a um
sorry a uh semicolon on the end
um so well we don't need this it depends
on where it's being used but in this
case it would be
so here is almost the action what we're
doing with the setting a variable equal
to this value or this value or we are
echoing something out now this might
confuse you so let's go ahead and put
this into into context
with regards to what we've just done
so i'm going to be placing this
functionality within the ternary
operator so we need to start off with
our old enough variable okay
and our old enough
variable is going to equal
note i put the equals in words before i
just had something and that's because we
could also do echo as well and we'll
look at that in in terms of this in a
moment anyway so old enough equals now
we have our condition so our condition
is basically just this so we can go
ahead and we can cut that and paste that
in there
now if this condition is met we just say
true now we could just leave it like
this um but what did we do is we'd be
best to get rid of
first of all this because we don't need
that we're setting this variable here to
true if this condition is met so we
fulfilled removing that
otherwise
we could say false so we've removed the
need to store an additional variable so
essentially all of the code i've just
removed can be done in one line as you
can see here
so you'll notice that when we refresh
our browser we have the same
functionality no errors
and again if we change the age to say 18
this condition is met therefore this is
true therefore this block here will be
executed so when we refresh we get old
enough
now what's interesting is we can
actually
apply the same
operator the ternary operator to this
block here
so we can actually instead of setting a
variable value like we've done here we
can actually echo out
and depending on the condition whether
it's met we can echo something otherwise
we can echo something else so we can say
echo and in brackets obviously you
wouldn't do an equals here
echo old enough
is equal to true so if old enough is
equal to true echo something here
otherwise echo something here okay so
we're just going to be echoing old
enough
here if this condition is met
and here
we're going to
echo not old enough
so let's pull this together uh we've
managed to shorten that into two lines
of code now and let's go ahead and check
this out in the browser so when i
refresh you see we get the same result
and again if i change this back to not
old enough
you can see that we get not old enough
so you can see
here although a useless example um we
have uh used the ternary operator to
shorten our code uh a significant amount
so that's essentially it you'll probably
find yourself you know it's hard to give
practical examples in short tutorials
you'll probably find you
you know you may have a series of if
statements and you might want to shorten
them and make it a bit more efficient
and in that case you'd use the ternary
operator as we've seen here we've uh you
know we've we've created this you know
efficiency here
so that's the the ternary operator in
php hi this is alex from php academy and
welcome to this tutorial on accessing
undefined function
parameters
in php
now in this video we're going to take a
look at a concept that involves creating
a function or defining a function
the code inside of it but not actually
defining any
parameters that the function takes and
we're going to use the example of a
function that adds two numbers together
and then we're going to look at creating
this function without the ability to
pass through uh specifically say number
one and number two and add them together
uh but we're going to allow an almost
unlimited i'm sure there is some limit
somewhere but an unlimited amount of
variables without having to define them
so we'll take a look at the problem that
we get if we are uh you know restricted
to defining them um and then we'll we'll
take a look at some practical examples
um and it's really really a good way of
of doing things if you if you you know
it's the correct way of doing things if
you need to pass a lot of a lot of
arguments or parameters to a function so
anyway let's go ahead and take a look at
a quick example
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
function called add
now if you've looked at functions before
you know that you can define
which
values can be passed to the function so
for example num1 comma num2 this means
that we can pass number 1 and number 2
to a function then we can do something
with it inside it return that value and
then we can use this outside of the
function
so let's go ahead and
return
or let's create another variable uh we
don't need to do this and it's probably
bad practice but just for the sake of
clarity i'll do so
so i'm going to say num1 plus num2 okay
so total now is equal to whatever we
pass here and whatever we pass here and
then we can return this value
and then pick this up outside so for
example i could say echo add
5 and 10 for example which is obviously
15.
um i'm echoing because i'm returning it
i'm not outputting anything within the
function which is again bad practice so
i'm echoing the result of this function
let's go ahead and take a look at the
result you see that's 15. so fairly
straightforward
now what happens if say i want to create
some kind of
calculator application that allows you
know a user to
i don't know go ahead and pass in 10
operations if you like add ad operations
um obviously you wouldn't just add in a
calculator but you you know you you get
my point
so we could say num1 num2 num3
num4
num5
this would only allow the user to enter
exactly five if we miss out uh
well let's do it with three and we'll
see what happens so if i just uh if i
just pass five and ten
and i say
plus num3 as well you'll see that we
should return an error yep so we've got
missing argument three for add called in
and it tells us where it's called and
where the function is defined and
everything
so we are now faced with the problem
where we have to pass now we could pass
a zero but then again this is terribly
pa bra bad practice because we are
defining um parameters that may not be
used so let's go ahead and take a look
at what we can do uh to to get around
this so i'll leave this here i'll get
rid of all of these
i'll get rid of everything in here as
well
now
the way we're going to do is we're not
going to define anything in here but
we're going to pick up what's been
passed to the function
within the function itself so we want to
pick up every value that's passed
through let's just change this to a one
so we'll get a result of 16 in the end
so let's go ahead and create our total
variable again but we'll do it this time
we'll set it just to zero so we've got a
standpoint to add on we're going to
increment
or you know append the value add the
value on
we're going to look at two functions one
of which we're going to use in the
example and one of which you'll you know
you may use outside of this
the first one is funk underscore
get arcs and this is a function uh what
this function does is it returns an
array of anything you pass to it
so you may know that we can use the
print r
statement uh to
um
show the result of an array so in this
case if i pass nothing so i'm going to
cut that out of there
go ahead and refresh you see that we
returned an array so essentially what
we're doing is well let's get rid of
this echo because we don't need that we
are printing the contents of this funk
get args array which is nothing it's an
empty array at the moment
let's go ahead and paste these values
back in so now what we should have is
this
funk git arg should return through an
array with three keys or three elements
to it first one's key zero key one and
key two and then here is the value of
everything that we've passed to our
function
so now we can be clever when we're not
getting any errors we haven't defined
anything in here but we're not getting
any errors by passing these values
what we can actually do is we can go
ahead and we can loop through this
functs array or the array that it
returns
and we can add these values onto total
and then output the result so we can
actually do this and then pass loads and
loads and loads of numbers through to it
so let's go ahead and do this we're
going to use a for each construct
and within here we're just essentially
looping through each element of an array
now we know that func get args returns
an array so we can say for each func get
args so for every element in that which
is essentially every element or every
parameter that you pass through as
arg
i'm going to say total
equals
total
plus
arg because remember arg is a number um
and we're just you know passing that
through
we could of course just say
total
plus equals arg that would just be a
shorter way of saying total equals total
plus arg
and we also might want to cast this to
an int now you wouldn't always want to
do this but we're um passing numbers
through so you know we want to go and
make sure these are numbers
uh now what we can do is underneath this
for each when that's looped through and
added everything we've passed through to
it we can go ahead and return the total
so return
total
so now if we go ahead and echo the
result of add 510 1 it will loop through
the first iteration of the loop will
this arg will equal five so total uh
plus um total equals total plus five
that would be five the second iteration
would be ten so that's fifteen and then
the third will be
uh one which is sixteen so now uh what
we'd expect to get is the value 16
returned so look at that we can go ahead
now and we can pass any number of
numbers um
into this and it will add all these up
for us and we don't even need to worry
about defining them within the function
now this isn't the most useful example
however there may be circumstances where
you are not sure of what data that you
want to pass through to a function for
example let's just say i'm not going to
demonstrate this visually but let's just
say that we have a function that
returns fields from a database let's say
user details from a database
you may want to leave this open so we
can you know pass
new new values in it and we don't have
to go back to our code and start you
know return up editing the parameters
that we get let's just say we we need to
pass in uh which fields that we want to
return from a user
a user row
we could say pass
like this i'll just quickly demonstrate
we could say pass first name
last name
um date of birth for example um and i
could just call this say user data now
user data would then loop through
each of these
it would uh pick pick this up within a
query so it would put these fields into
a query
and then it would go ahead and return
that result set so again i'm not going
to show you because it's beyond the
scope of this tutorial but there's a
variety of ways you might need to do
this and of course
you may want to go ahead and you may
want to pass
you may want to pass a value into here
as well so we're going to take a quick
look at
funk get arg as well as funky args so
let's go ahead and just get rid of this
uh and here i'm going we'll just say i
know add
in fact let's say um append
no we'll we'll call the function append
and then we'll call that uh
call the function
so append
now i want an initial string
and
i want to
be able to pass through a value to this
the initial string and then supplying
any amount of parameters on here to
append to it so again useless but it
demonstrates that we can pass one
parameter and then an unlimited amount
of parameters as well
so i want to append um
uh let's just say i want to append my
surname onto my first name we'll add a
space in here we'll do all that in a
minute but it's just to demonstrate how
this can work um so append initial so
what we need to do is we need to
um let's go ahead and say
we'll say result equals nothing for now
uh okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to make uh we're going to
take a look first of all at the
funk get arg
value so
a function sorry so i'm going to say
funk get arg
and i'm going to specify zero now this
is a function but it it it basically
takes as the the parameter the key of
what you have what you're passing so we
can pick out uh particular uh values in
here so let's just say we wanted to just
return the initial value
i could go ahead and echo append
and i could go ahead and refresh and you
see we just got alex here okay so notice
that php hasn't errored because we've
passed an extra parameter even though
we've defined one it will only error if
you don't pass all of them uh all the
parameters that are
defined in here so if we were to pass
nothing we'd get that error
okay so now let's look at taking uh
making this work so i'm going to go
ahead and i'm going to say
four each
and again for each uh funk get args as
arg this time i'm going to make a slight
change and i'm going to say key
and arg so basically i'm grabbing the
key which would be 0 1 2 3 4 blah blah
blah and then the arg which will be the
value so i could probably call this
value it'd make a bit more sense
so what i can do now is
in fact just to demonstrate let me go
ahead and echo out key
and we've got zero and one because we've
passed two so this is zero
this is one
so now what i can do is i can create a
quick if statement in here
and i'm gonna say if key
is greater than or equal to one
then we want to say result
dot equals so again the same as plus
equals but we're pending this time so
dot equals uh space
and then we can append on the value okay
so we're essentially saying um append or
with the result um
sorry we're saying
for any of the keys which are greater
than zero so ignoring this
append this on to the result
obviously the result needs the initial
value on so at the moment we just have
oops
we're not returning anything let's just
go ahead and return
result at the moment this will just
return uh space and then garrett you can
see or where it won't return a space
because we've not got anything in front
of it
um
so um what we need to do is we need to
make use of the funk get arg function so
what we can say is result initially
equals func get arg
zero so we're setting the result
initially to the first parameter that we
pass and then for every other parameter
we're adding a space and then that
parameter so alex garrett
refresh and now says alex garrett i can
then say alex
james garrett and it will do exactly the
same thing so it will loop through
ignoring this first
pass parameter and it will just depend
on it every time now you might be
thinking why is this useful well think
about it this way if you are say
registering a user in i don't know
on your website and you ask them for um
you know an array of names so you could
or an array of values anything i don't
know it could be um different keywords
for say a video upload say tags for a
video upload anything like that that's
separated out of course we could use
things like explode but depending on how
you're adding them if you're using
different fields you could you know
append things together or well you
wouldn't but this is essentially an
example but i think it's quite a good
example to to show you how to use the
funky arc funky args blah
this for each if you're new to this and
and skipping over this first result
anyway that is how we um pass um
parameters that we don't find uh in php
it's an extremely useful technique which
saves you a lot of time and also
application speed as well